investigators in Durham North Carolina
want to know if construction workers
triggered a gas leak that caused a
deadly downtown explosion firefighters
were evacuating people from the area
where the massive blast destroyed one
building and damaged others blocks away
61 year old coffee shop owner Cong Lee
was killed 17 people were hurt
Erol Barnett is near the scene in Durham
Erol good morning good morning folks s
so saddened to hear of mr. Connelly's
passing but to give you a sense of just
how powerful this blast was you can see
it left an imprint of debris on that
building behind me this was truly heard
and felt throughout the city beyond
damaging buildings here at left mr.
Connelly's coffee shop in rubble thick
black smoke from the explosion poured
into the sky as first responders rushed
to help the injured one more unit as the
fire began spreading students at the
nearby Durham School of the Arts were
loaded onto buses and evacuated from the
area one firefighter was among people
seriously injured Fire Chief Robert
zeldo sprays the first responders I
don't know how many people they evacuate
and got them out of the hazard zone
prior to the explosion but obviously
they put their lives in line to do it
and I'm sure there's people they saved
because of it Marconi who spoke only
with CBS News lives directly across from
the blast site the blast was so powerful
it blew out your front door front door
it's blown in half
at the bottom of the window of the door
itself is it's was out in the hallway
Bocconi typically works from home but
went to the office for a meeting
yesterday well thankfully you want that
thankfully yeah you know things happen
for the right reasons sometimes
at me at least me today city officials
that met utility workers were installing
fiber optic cables all over town but
they weren't won't confirm who was
operating in this area and as for mark
and other residents here they still have
not been told when they can return home
John all right Darryl thank you
lucky day for Marconi thanks again
they're all